in modern times we look back at the
Nazis Third Reich and wonder how on
earth anyone could have followed Adolphe
Hitler and him so clearly an evil
dictator well this was all thanks to
Yusuf girdle's the minister of
propaganda he knew exactly how to
manipulate the minds of a nation with
fake news Nazi idealized books and
propaganda films Goebbels was
single-handedly responsible for
brainwashing entire populations and
destroying people who were caught in his
web of lies today or via graphics you're
going to learn how one man convinced
millions of normal German people to all
become faithful Nazis Paul Joseph
Goebbels was born on October the 29th
1897 in a small town outside of
Dusseldorf his father Fritz worked in a
factory and his mother stayed at home to
take care of him and his four other
siblings his family never had a lot of
money but they still paid for him to go
to a private all-boys Roman Catholic
High School Gyrls was born with a
disability where the bone marrow of his
feet never developed properly and he had
a clubfoot
his parents paid for him to have an
operation in order to correct the issue
but even when both of his feet were
pointing in the right direction he still
needed to wear a metal brace on his leg
for the rest of his life this operation
it stunted his growth and one leg was
permanently shorter than the other
causing him to have a limp he also had
chronically inflamed lungs and got sick
very often he grew up to be very angry
at the world and he felt that life was
unfair he decided to focus a lot of his
time and energy into reading books and
getting good grades this disability
prevented him from doing military
service during World War one he was able
to earn an academic scholarship and
attended the University of Heidelberg he
stayed in school for years and earned a
PhD in philosophy in 1921 at this point
he completely rejected the teachings of
the Catholic Church he wrote about his
personal ideas of how he thought the
world should be and saw himself as a
great philosopher and a thinker
unfortunately then though well
no one else agreed he was very loud and
outspoken and was always trying to get
noticed even then he was very
anti-semitic and many of his opinions
were so hateful that the articles and
books were rejected for publication he
decided to create his own publication
for his opinions but very few people
actually cared to read it by all
accounts he was a failed writer and an
incredibly damaged little man he made a
bit of money being a tutor and finally
sold a few articles but other than that
he had this alter no money to speak off
all of this motivated him to join the
Nazi Party in 1924 at this time Germany
was going through a tremendous financial
depression and the Nazis promised that
they would fix the country with the
Nazis girls he finally found a home and
a group of people who were actually
willing to read as hateful work they
thought that he was absolutely great at
creating Pro Nazi propaganda indeed it
was good enough to convince new members
to join the party his work indeed helped
get Adolphe Hitler elected when he rose
to power Hitler appointed girdle's as
the minister of propaganda since he was
unemployed at the time this very
literally changed everything overnight
suddenly his life had meaning and he
truly looked up to Adolphe Hitler as
well his best friends and indeed as
Savior Hitler gave Goebbels the task of
censoring any media that may conflict
with Nazi ideals he began to give the
order of burning books that were written
by certain authors some of the books
that Goebbels destroyed medal of a sense
like the socialist philosophy of Karl
Marx however some of the choices of
banned authors seem to be a bit random
and there's no real logical explanation
as to why Goebbels would want to erase
them from history this has led some
people to speculate that he wanted to
destroy certain authors just out of
petty jealousy that they were better
writers than he was this gave him a
taste of authority and a taste of
control and he loved it
aside from censoring the media Goebbels
set out to create new contents in order
to replace it
Colonels new of at one of the most
powerful ways to incite emotions in
human beings was through movies the
largest film studio in Berlin is called
the universe and film acting and gazelle
shaft or the UFA for short they were
well respected throughout the world for
producing beautiful silent films like
metropolis in 1927 one of Goebbels as
first orders of business was to forcibly
take the studio over on behalf of the
Nazi government both girls and Hitler
were huge movie buffs but they made the
decision to censor American films from
the public Adolf Hitler still had all of
the new releases from Hollywood in his
personal collection but no one in the
general population was ever allowed to
see them Joseph Goebbels set out to make
sure that everyone working in the German
film industry was loyal to Hitler any of
the actors who refused to shun any
Jewish people from their lives and
joined the Nazi Party were blacklisted
from ever working again many of them
were even prevented from leaving the
country and some actors even chose to
commit suicide actresses from throughout
Europe who auditioned for the
prestigious UFA studio had no idea that
they were walking into a trap and many
of them signed multi-year contracts
before the Nazis came into power so
while there were some actors he would
not cease many of them were forced to
participate in these films against their
will
girl set out to create German versions
of some of the big blockbuster hits in
America he also created movies where the
only goal was to brainwash people into
believing Nazi ideals some of them were
clearly propaganda like one called
Hitler Youth quacks but other films were
cleverly disguised subtly changing the
opinions of Germans to suit the needs of
the Nazis for example the 1941 movie I
accuse was orchestrated to get the
general population to agree with the Act
E&T for program which pushed for the
euthanization of disabled and terminally
ill people the plot of I accused is
about a doctor at the peak of his career
he gets married to a beautiful young
woman no need to find out that she has
been diagnosed with MS back then the
treatment for MS was nothing like it is
today and there's no cure for the
disease this means that the wife was
dying a very slow and painful death she
begged them to give her a lethal
injection so she could be put out of her
misery he struggled with the decision
but ultimately
in her suicide much of the movie takes
place in a court of law where they are
trying to decide if this man should be
guilty of murder or if he was doing her
a favor by killing her does my meaning a
propaganda film it's actually very well
written even today anyone who watches
the film may find themselves questioning
their own morals which is why I was
considered to be one of the most
dangerous propaganda films ever made the
movie convinced people that assisted
suicide was only going to help their
friends and family members who were
suffering so the action t4 program it
was passed innocent people were then
taken from their homes and killed in the
name of a perfect master race the same
kind of brainwashing it happened over
and over again in the movies
[Music]
the Nazi Party didn't just help Goebbels
career it also helped him get into a
relationship after graduating from his
all-boys school he was not used to
speaking to girls at 34 years old in
1931 he married a fellow Nazi named
Magda Hitler was the best man at their
wedding in the public eye they appeared
to have the perfect German marriage they
had several children together and they
lived on a huge gated compound in the
woods outside of Berlin however years of
Goebbels had a reputation for
objectifying women and since he was
surrounded by beautiful actresses he
completely took advantage of his
position according to the testimony of a
woman named Anneliese Oleg she was given
the starring role in one of the movies
that was made at the UFA studio girls
asked her if she wanted to go for a
drive and talk about the movie and he
drove her straight to his compound he
offered her a drink and began to force
himself on her she started kicking and
screaming and got free from him he said
that if she did not meet his demands he
would make sure that she never had a
career in the movies she decided to take
her chances and ran out of the door
thus when she showed up the next day to
work there was an announcement that the
film was cancelled and Oleg was
blacklisted from ever working in Germany
again yes if girls did this to women on
a regular basis but he did actually fall
in love with one woman named Leda bar
over she was one of the few actresses he
was truly a faithful Nazi and she even
turned down opportunities to work in
Hollywood in favor of moving to Germany
she moved from Prague to Berlin in 1935
and married an actor named gustav
fröhlich Froelich had divorced his
Jewish wife in order to continue his
successful acting career according to
lead a bar over she felt pressured into
being in a relationship with Yosef
garbles because she had heard of all of
the stories about him ruining other
actors careers she knew that if she said
no there was a huge chance that she and
her husband would never work again but
she must have been a good actress
because he became convinced that they
should run away together girls told his
wife Magda about the affair and said
that he wanted a divorce
Magda went straight out of Hitler saying
that near a bar ever was seducing him
and tried to tear the marriage part
gurbles begged Hitler's permission to
get a divorce he also wanted to move to
Japan and give up his position of power
he was willing to give up everything in
order to be with leader but even as one
of the most powerful Nazis in the Third
Reich house if Goebbels was still a
prisoner
to Hitler's power Hitler refused to let
girls quit his job because he was far
too valuable to the Nazi cause the two
men got into a screaming match that was
witnessed and heard by dozens of people
Hitler urged him to give his
relationship with Magda the second
chance he insisted that they give
themselves another three months of
living together to try and repair the
relationship if they could not fix their
marriage within those three months then
he could get a divorce
Hitler order laid a bar over to leave
Germany within 24 hours giving her a
one-way ticket to Prague after this
incident Joseph Goebbels who is no
longer one of Hitler's favorite men his
wife also hated him and his lover was
gone he was no longer invited over to
dinner at Hitler's place and they barely
even spoke the other higher up Nazis
they believe that girdles had become
weak and that he was going insane they
questioned his loyalty and he was no
longer seen as the powerful man that he
once was if he wanted to be back in good
graces with Hitler he would need to do
something extreme
[Music]
Gerber's was desperate to regain
hitler's trust so in 1939 he incited a
mob by publishing a fake story in the
newspaper that said a German man had
been shot by a Jewish man in Paris he
spoke in the streets claiming that the
Jews were trying to destroy society he
led an angry mob to burn down a
synagogue that same year he travelled to
Poland with a documentary film crew to
show what life was like inside of a
Jewish ghetto the people living in the
ghetto and sunken faces wore rags and
were generally dirty and sick we now
know that this is because the Nazis
forced them into inhumane conditions in
the first place
however gurbles took this as an
opportunity to compare them to animals
saying that they were choosing to live
that way he said that they were less
human and that they needed to be
exterminated
this film was called the eternal Jew and
it premiered in 1940 in this movie he
tried to say that Jews were all
criminals and that if the Nazis ever
lost the war then they may take over the
world forcing the German people to live
in squalor humanity would sink into
eternal darkness it would fall into a
dull and primitive state where the Jews
to win this war they are the incarnation
of that destructive force that in these
terrible years has guided the enemy war
leadership into a fight against all that
we see as noble beautiful and worth
keeping for that reason alone the Jews
hate us they despise our culture and
learning which they perceive as towering
over their nomadic worldview they fear
our economic and social standards which
leave no room for their parasitic drives
this documentary is genuinely frightened
the German people and they felt that
concentration camps were absolutely
justified
after visiting Auschwitz in person
Joseph Goebbels wrote that the death and
torture of these prisoners was so
gruesome
that he did not even want to write the
details in his private journal he wrote
it may be barbaric but they truly
deserve it all of his efforts to incite
hate against the Jewish people they paid
off and dad off Hitler began to trust
Joseph garbles once again their mutual
hate was enough to repair their
friendship but it was that the cost of
millions of lives at this point Hitler
began to trust Joseph Goebbels with more
decisions in the government since he had
even more power than he did before
Hitler stopped making so many public
appearances and allowed Goebbels to
speak on his behalf instead he even gave
him the authority to declare war in 1941
Goebbels announced over the radio that
Germany would be going to war with the
Soviet Union garbles did exactly what he
did when he filmed the eternal Jew in
Poland he brought yet another
documentary film crew to show Soviet
prisoners who were living in the mud the
King half debt he claims that this is
how Russian people normally lived since
that the Bolshevik Party was controlled
by Jews who were trying to take over the
world he successfully convinced the
German public that by fighting Russia
they were fighting for their freedom he
stood in front of a crowd of thousands
of people at a sports stadium in Berlin
saying that there needed to be a total
war this was met with thunderous
applause but as he may already know
Germany's invasion of Russia is what led
to their downfall the Germans could not
handle the harsh winters in the United
States that joins the Allied forces
Italy switched over to the Allies as
well and their stronghold in World War
two it was suddenly falling like
dominoes
[Music]
now you can probably tell so far in this
story that Joseph Goebbels was always a
bit crazy but after the invasion of the
Soviet Union his mental state became
more and more unraveled he encouraged
elderly men and young boys to sacrifice
their lives for the sake of Germany and
baby-faced child soldiers were even sent
off to war he said that every man woman
and child needed to be ready to die for
the motherland
according to Villefort van oven a man
who worked on Joseph Goebbels his staff
they were at a meeting when a bomb was
dropped in the garden of his house the
glass of all the windows shattered while
everyone else on the staff ducked for
cover yes if Goebbels never even
flinched
he just brushed the broken glass of his
notes and continued reading his speech
as if nothing had happened
he somehow remained completely composed
on the outside while the panic inside
was tearing in a part at the end of the
war Hitler told girdle's that he knew
that they were going to lose the war he
was preparing to go to his bunker with
plans to commit suicide he appointed
Goebbels as the new chancellor of
germany and he wanted him to stay behind
and run the government once the Allies
invaded
gurbles was so devoted that he simply
refused to live without Hitler he told
his wife and all of his children to
clean themselves put on their Sunday
best and go to the Fuehrer's bunker on
April the 30th Hitler committed suicide
leaving garbles as Germany's new
Chancellor it's not a position he would
hold for long though
the following day Goebbels and Magda
poisoned their six children before
ending their own lives as well so I'm
not going to ask if you enjoyed that
video but I do hope you found it
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe also feel like there's
something else to watch I've got another
channel called today I found out you'll
find that linked to on the screen as
well as below this video and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Applause]